so I'm I'm a maker I like to make things
and this is my biggest project that I've
ever made and it's in 8 by 8 by 8 red
green blue cube of lights each light is
sitting underneath a ping-pong ball
which have all been drilled
that's 512 ping pong balls that have
been drilled to diffuse the light it's
actually really simple because in the
base of the new pixels neopixels is the
brand name it's like a ws2812 B and it's
just basically one strip of lights so
it's actually just 512 lights here that
are connected together like Christmas
tree lights so when one doesn't work the
next hundred won't work unfortunately
and they can control any
microcontrollers that can control in the
epical library so you got Arduino
Raspberry Pi but my favorite is the
micro bit just because it's so small and
cheap kids can code this so you can use
like the scratch like language make code
which is like blocks to code to this
cube which is what I'm really hoping
that people will do this weekend is
they'll they'll hack the cube and put
their own designs in it I'm really
boring I don't have any anime
imagination so right now just doing the
test grid of red green blue a lot of
people just the cubes they make them
animations which is a bit boring so I
thought I'd make it interactive so on
this cube because you can control each
individual light you can play snake on
it so you can play 3d snake so you move
the snake in around the cube to eat the
apple
you can play pac-man so the ghost chase
you and try and eat you so that's what
I've done but again I just want people
to make their own games like it gives
you two player pong microp it has an
accelerometer on it so you've got lots
of potential for movement and dance of
what you can make to interact with the
cube rather than watching someone else's
designs you know interact and make your
own designs so it's the BBC micro bit
it's like a character age so you just
take out the test one and that will stop
and then you put the snake one in the
back lights might not work so this is
the snake the green ball and that red
ball is the Apple so you have to use
controller to get from the frontier to
the back which is really hard because
you're driving in three dimensions the
average score is only about five to five
apples the max score though is 20 some
go
really impressive we got 20 oh yeah
that's a sneak I really love to do
Tetris though I just I spend so much
time building this and assembling and
bringing places that I don't get to code
it at home you know it's never built at
home it's always in the car so I'd love
to do 3d Tetris because that would be
particularly evil and difficult to play
and code so the frame is the is the
wiring so each each wires ground and
power and data so data in from here data
in data out data in data out so there's
three wires going between each light and
it goes like that so it's a bit awkward
to code because this is like zero this
is like seven this is like eight this is
like 15 because of the way the data
travels so yeah the frame is the wiring
which is what's brilliant about it looks
neat it looks like a cube when it's lit
up in the dark it looks really good lots
of connections and this is version 2 so
this is much more reliable than version
1 because of these copper rods so the
first one was steel these are copper
coated iron rods so they're stronger and
they're easier to solder onto so the
first version it was a galvanized steel
which is the worst thing ever to try and
solder on T and so the first one we had
eight spare columns and eventually went
through all then because I eventually
broke this one I have no spare columns
and it's been fine I've brought a I've
brought to Ireland I've brought it to
game coderdojo I brought pie Wars been
to Leeds Newcastle so yeah this is this
travels a lot better there's a lot of
sturdier it's it's awkward because the
size of it but if that's don't like
these each of these columns come out and
it travels it fits in the boot my
husband's care and that's it that's
nothing another bill anything bigger
because it needs to fit in and not but
I'm not renting a van from my next
project so this is MF where am i this is
hopefully you'll be at PyCon in Cardiff
so the the Python conference goes if you
can use a micro Python obviously the
Raspberry Pi to control it as you can
use Python to do it and then I work at
Lancaster University it's at they're
dying for me to leave this in the foyer
of the computer science building and
they'll they'll hack it that's why I
want I want people to hack I want it to
go somewhere where people will actually
make things for its rather than a
display piece
[Music]
mr. Tom if anyone can figure that out
once you get inside it's pretty hard to
confuse them for a working toilet
[Music]